this isn't like in the anime at all
oh my god has connor broken another car
joey pulls the drift off i'll give him
another hand job as promised
welcome everybody to a special episode
of trash taste a non-podcast episode yes
welcome to trash taste outside i trust
is outside is that what we're going to
call that guest so trash tastes outside
so today in this special episode of
trash taste we went all the way to
northern japan to do a drifting trash
taste special where we learn to drift
and if you're joey learn to drive a car
but it's not a tress test episode
without some kind of drifting challenge
and of course the loser has to have some
kind of forfeit unlike every good
forfeit it involves food and the loser
will be paying for the dinner and it
won't be me so only one of us will be
the drifter king don't worry this won't
replace your normal podcast this is just
a one-off special that we are just
trying out so we hope you enjoy what you
see
bye do the intro
drifting a dangerous looking hobby you
normally associate with video games
movies or classic anime with plenty of
eurobeat you may think this is something
reserved for professional racers and
illegal street racers but here in japan
you can not only learn and take part in
the sport but you don't even need a
driver's license which sounds completely
irresponsible luckily we have a group of
three idiots just for the job we will
have to travel up north to fukushima to
japan's biggest drift course
ebisu circuit
we were about to take our first step
into one of japan's most dangerous sport
and the night before we were feeling
fine besides what could we even be
nervous about we're in fukushima voice
how do we feel yeah are we not yeah we
are okay how already how ready can we be
i've never done anything close to this
so i don't really know what to expect
honestly i've like skidded a car once
is this just basically go-karting with
attitude that's that's what i feel
that's what i'm gonna call it from now
i mean do you guys feel confident are
you ready to drift no no i haven't
driven manual since i passed my driving
test when i was 17.
so it's been
13 years yeah like 13 years since i've
lost driven
last time
last time i've never driven man what do
you mean i'm typical asian driver i
drive automatically or nothing you
didn't have to do your driver's test
manual no you also agreed to go drifting
you know it's in manual right yeah i
know it's in manual that's why do you
think i was so unconfident at the
beginning i know how to drive manual in
theory
what do you mean in theory like you
passed the theory test of how to know no
no no like i know just how to do it like
you know you have to let go of the
accelerator while you pull i mean in
theory i know how to like skate and ice
skate yeah it's just one foot forward
right and the other foot i mean to be
fair i haven't driven a car just an
automatic in about three years so just i
think getting behind the wheel is just
gonna make me [ __ ] myself when's the
last time you drove period three years
ago
what
i'm driving
i live in tokyo you don't have to drive
let alone drift
[ __ ] i am [ __ ]
that's why i hope to god that at least
my time in the passenger seat is going
to be very nice are they going to give
us helmets i [ __ ] hope so
i'm pretty sure i know we can prepare
though adequately
how you know what dk stands for
donkey kong
with the suitable research in place we
were ready to take on the real thing we
were ready
to take on the drift course so we all
drifting today right
i think this is the right place i think
so
why is there llamas
there's a camel over there
it's a go right there
i can hear it this is a zoo
oh
well i mean that's a oh that's nice
well then very nice should we go
drifting yeah let's do it why not
very nice well looks like these are our
cars
and that looks more like it but there's
no honda civic here i'm not used to
driving that's got a spoiler who's
getting one car
i want the white one i want to be pimped
out man that looks like the most pink
without i think the spoiler looks like
that's for uconn yeah i feel like i'm a
spoiler kind of guy right i have a small
dick and i'll take the one with the
massive cone
i think that comes with the color
yeah that cone's for you yeah yeah
this guy's gonna crash
i'm gonna die today we have no clue how
to drift a car so the first thing we're
going to be doing is letting the pros
teach us how to do it and we're going to
all experience it one by one
at very fast feed this is going to sound
safe and exciting i've got food
poisoning right now he's going to [ __ ]
himself and i hope the g's don't make my
[ __ ] come out with what i'm about to
experience just squeeze it out it's
going to be a tradition every trash
tastes special one of us has the [ __ ] i
don't know why every time we do
something one of us is food poisoning
today it's me i woke up with food
poisoning this is this is great it's
comforting knowing that if i get you
know too stressed out i can go and ride
a camel over there all right little
gentlemen who wants to go first
do you want to rock over scissors all
right fair enough how are we doing this
we'll just uh win the winner all right
okay winner gets to go first right sorry
sure no no no no no no no
you get the honor of going first jerry
he's probably going to [ __ ] himself
let's be honest i think i'm gonna [ __ ]
myself
i don't know how like intense this guy's
gonna go
but i'm hoping it's uh not
not too intense
let's go you know when we had an idea
for a trash taste special
we definitely went like for the most
dangerous options straight away didn't
we we didn't we could have gone ice
cream making or sushi making experience
maybe no let's go drifting we just went
from like zero to 100 straight away how
did we go from buying figures no chess
tournament
[Laughter]
this is going to be scary isn't it
not scary okay i trust you i trust you
yeah yeah oh here we go oh here we go
holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh jesus christ jesus [ __ ]
cry
holy [ __ ]
oh
that was a clean drift all right i'm
good i'm good
oh my god oh [ __ ]
oh my god it's so much faster than i'm
doing
i'm sweating so hard
it's not just the helmet how was that
how was that joke
that was dude your shit's gonna come
flying out
i guarantee that was so fun
but hold my god your body just got
thrown around how was
dude there's too many g's
when he [ __ ] accelerates into that
corner it was one of the most scariest
things i've ever because that long drift
was insane he did like a 20 second drift
yeah i could actually feel the car doing
this like
really yeah i i reckon i reckon like one
of the sides of the car actually came
off the ground slightly you hate roller
coasters and you're [ __ ] oh dude like
after this i can go on any roller
coaster like this is just a roller
coaster with no rails that can also i
feel more in danger on this than any
roller coaster oh definitely well in a
roller coaster you're locked into a rail
yeah on this you can roll the car and
die painfully so you know it's take your
poison yeah the idea was
i think it was god's wasn't here
if someone dies we're suing gone
and if god dies well then
well then i had it coming i'm calling it
god's gonna vomit i'm betting money on
it he's gonna vomit right now it's
pretty intense like i don't get carsick
often but i was pretty sick you saw how
a short guy was right dude nice dude
watch this car you gotta [ __ ] yourself
it's insane
oh my god it looks terrifying doesn't it
oh my he's going so fast
jesus christ the poop is flying out of
this man's [ __ ] pants right now his
cheeks so hard on his life
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god there's smoke coming out of
that oh dude yeah the whole track is
smoke when you're done
there's chunks of tyres flying i just
hurt did you hear that
i think i actually heard one of the
tires like bits of the tire pop maybe we
should have done like another chess
tournament instead you know just
something else for a special i don't
have a day at the zoo my stomach feels
queasy in preparation
how was it
are you okay so much fun
i'm like i'm like calming down right now
like i'm like oh yeah i know right oh
give me a second to let this adrenaline
like wash out my body
i'm not excited for this
i think it'll be fun once i get in it's
just really anxious to like you're a
thrill seeker right yeah i do i do love
my thrill seeks
my thrills that i see that is there's
something about deciding your own fate
though and not having someone else do it
right i want to [ __ ] it up if i die it's
on me all right off you go man
all right gamers wish me luck no death
[Music]
you're instilling me with confidence
i think he's gonna enjoy it
oh my god jesus christ
holy [ __ ] jesus [ __ ]
oh my god look at the [ __ ] smoke
coming off that thing
this isn't liking the anime at all
oh [ __ ] sweating on my ass oh there he
is he's got a big smile on his face
that's good very fun very fun
yeah i'd do it again yeah that's pretty
fun bro your [ __ ] exhaust was like
those flames are coming out
[Music]
that clutch sounded like it was dying
well we've all got an experience of uh
[ __ ] what it's supposed to be like i
thought your car was gonna [ __ ] flip
yeah yeah
so we're gonna try to recreate
it we're not gonna be able to do
anything but first we need to learn how
to drive manually yeah i got to learn
how to start the car first i reckon i
can make a a singular drift
one crumb of a drift my goal for this
for this day is to make one sick drift
yeah one drift if i can if i can get one
drift i'm good oh yes learning manually
through a white board let's draw a penis
yeah that is definitely a penis that's a
dick that's a big deal that's a red dick
perhaps you're saying you need a giant
dick to drift high rpm
spinning
we should probably turn the mics off nah
dude that mudan i want you to hear me
shooting myself our first task was to do
a donut which was easier said than done
unfortunately before i could even
attempt that garnet and i had to learn
the basics of driving a car
so i'm just doing some pricing just to
make sure i remember how to drive manual
in a while
but it seems like i remember joey's
[ __ ] stalling the car right now
oh god what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
jesus christ this is hot okay first gear
let go of the brakes slowly put it off
okay okay okay
that was cool
[Music]
dude this clutch is so [ __ ]
sensitive i feel like such a failure man
how do i ever pass this driving test
on top of that i had other problems i
was dealing with at least i've stored
less than joey to be fair this is the
first time he's driven manual there's a
massive [ __ ] bee
why don't i keep stalling
okay got it got it got it
guys there is a [ __ ] bee in here
right now
i ain't playing around
if anything's going to make me crash
it's this [ __ ] bee
oh my god that is a massive bee unlike
these boys however that was just a
straight-up natural
jesus
okay
oh yes i stopped it without a stalling
all right now i know how to do it please
get out please please is that a bee
oh it's not even a [ __ ] sort of
[ __ ] bee yeah that's a [ __ ] fly so
they've been going about 15 minutes
connor's the only one so far who's
successfully done some drifting the
other two
struggling a little bit because it's a
manual driven manual driven cars it's a
little bit tricky eventually we would
all be attempting donuts and it wasn't
too bad
if i wasn't stalling the car
oh [ __ ] this shouldn't be this hard
[ __ ] elvis [ __ ] clutch
[ __ ]
well i completely span out this is a lot
of fun
he did it
i think connor's already got the [ __ ]
drift down meanwhile i'm [ __ ] peasant
over here learning how to drive the
goddamn thing take three tokyo drift
can you see how much smoke i'm [ __ ]
making right now
oh my god this is so hard
[Music]
i can't remember how many takes this is
i haven't done one full rotation
around the cone yet
here goes joey
holy [ __ ] that's for me i was the only
one who couldn't pull off a single donut
connor's doing way better than me at
least he's not spitting out every
[ __ ] time
[Music]
he's pretty good
he's a natural was that connor man that
was that was fun that was scary but
you are absolutely sweating yeah look at
me now when you sit in that car it's
like a furnace immediately every time
you do a drift even if it's terrible you
have to pay the price of all the smoke
and the heat gun and all the smoke yeah
yeah you created an artificial clown
but you got the hang of it pretty well
in about it took about 20 minutes
and you're the first one if i'm not the
best i can at least say i was the first
right to get it get it down that's gotta
get a take of win where we can get one
it was fun watching joey in just his
face of distraught out the window he
would do a drift and he's like
i wanna go and see what they're doing
god's made a cloud
he's getting the hang of it i think
we've missed it god's just been left to
his own devices yeah they just left him
in the car my guy kept cheering me on
every time i [ __ ] up i wanted to beat
myself up but he was like good
oh that was decent that was decent look
at joey he's just standing there like
[ __ ] what have i got myself into jerry
looks very defeated i don't want to say
he's going to quit but i could
definitely see jake throwing in the
towel oh wow joey's oh joey's just got
it
[Music]
he's got it
[Applause]
[Music]
he's getting it he just needs to link
them now we were practicing so hard
that not everyone made it out in one
piece we've got an injury we've got to
get this on hd come on up joey come tell
us about it i'm like on the cusp of like
vomiting and not vomiting right now you
like the mangaka of hunter hunter like
oh
my thumb hurts i can't go on
well not only did i [ __ ] up my thumb
here but this knuckle is killing me
what did you do
how hard are you gripping this thing
well really hard because
you don't even hold it that hard you
just swoosh it around i dude i'm like
struggling for dear life i mean i think
you think you're doing better than gone
we should just do a thing be like it's
gone it's totally gone god's doing it
this is so hard let's get the drone out
let's drone it
jeremy being sick in a field he's chris
chatting [ __ ] again no no no it's just
talking about his ass
joey's being sick oh no
after boiling ourselves in 30 degrees
celsius heat in cars with zero ac
overheating our engines driving circles
around a cone for hours
some of us needed a break what do you
call a hand camel with three humps
i don't know what'd you call a camel
with three humps pregnant
all right
get away from me mainly that looks just
like a grass guard that looks exactly
like a great sky well that's because of
gretzko is also a red panda kind of a
copyright claim i'd say so this is where
you go for lunch when you're done
drifting there is a safari restaurant
right there i feel seasick and food
poisoning at the same time they have
ramen joey ramen nah don't talk to me
about ramen man this friend's dying i'm
actually feeling so sick are you really
yeah
i don't know how you have so much energy
yeah it's so fun i don't know it's it i
don't i don't feel sick when i'm driving
it maybe if he drifted me again i might
i just want to keep driving
like just driving around not like
drifting i just want to drive
driving was fun right
yeah when i can get the car
is it harder or easier than you thought
it was going to be way harder wait you
thought it would be easy
no but i thought at least be able to get
the basics down press the drift button
like in mario kart where's the drift
button right yeah where's the r trigger
initiate the jump drift
i actually found that the drifting part
is easier than i thought it's just like
the driving
i can confidently say that drifting is
easier than manual driving it was so
funny joey joey going oh yeah i can
drift it when i can get it into position
but i just can't get into position cause
i just keep stalling out car i can't
even i can't even it's like i end it
right and i'm usually like completely
spun out so the cones on the left on me
and the guy's like okay get it in
position where the cones on the right
and i stall like seven times before i
can finally get it into position are we
going on another track
i love chris chris you guys can't see
chris expression he's [ __ ] giggling
away behind the camera at the thought of
us going on the actual track right we've
decided we need to spice it up a little
bit there's a stuffed animal store here
we thought we need to get a mascot each
for our car to you know ganbare to help
us win i want to win one of the red
pandas i want i want a gretzko next to
me scream i want a red panda i think we
all want the right one to get a red
panda then what are the choices you see
the red panda or depressed lion or
depressed polar bear as
well that's a hundred and fifty thousand
yen why is that one thousand five
hundred dollars you could have a day of
drifting or you could get that big red
panda big red panda
okay
that's got me energy right back on what
are you going for i mean elephants like
the national thai animals yeah exactly i
guess hey i guess i've got to represent
thailand right i think now with the
imbued confidence of an animal friend i
can drift maybe i just won't throw up
that's that's my plan i got something to
throw up on
so with mixed morale on the progress
we've made we thought it would be a good
idea to see how the pros actually did it
on a real course and luckily there were
some pros practicing just next door we
asked if they would let us on the course
and they just straight up said no and
we're probably going to see why now
needless to say i don't think we're
going to be getting uh
that good
this session nah oh you can't he's going
to test some ass this red car you
shouldn't say that that red car has
giant nuts absolutely giant nut sack
massive ball i saw the exhaust on that
thing too it's [ __ ] massive
i can't emphasize how [ __ ] loud this
is so loud so well so [ __ ] loud god i
wish we were that good god i wish that
was me
god i wish my dick was that big jeez
the sound of that exhaust
[Music]
that gives you so much anxiety when they
like spin it one way and then spin it
the other way immediately oh you slowed
down you [ __ ] it up you botched it but
yeah when you get to that level must be
so [ __ ] fun right
like that corner is way tighter than it
looks yeah oh look at that
god this screen oh my god that's so
clean
[Music]
that's so [ __ ] cool yeah sex is cool
but have you ever watched close combat
drifting i'm just do now i've seen
enough i'm satisfied
so aside from the fact that we are like
10 minutes away from getting a heat
stroke because it's so [ __ ] hot out
here i don't even know if the mic is
picking up what we're saying i know it's
so loud now that we've seen
what how fast these cars can go around
these corners we're gonna get inside one
of those i'm gonna throw up and [ __ ] my
pants at the same time well we didn't
just want to stop there we wanted to
truly experience these courses as a pro
drifter we just needed a driver crazy
enough to take us all around and luckily
we found just that some say he watched
all of one piece in a day
and has listened to so much eurobeat he
has an honorary passport to estonia he's
not the stake
but all we know is
he's called
the drift to king
okay let's go
our driver was an ex-drift champion and
as he was showing us the track he was
about to drive
he seemed to be enjoying our
suffering why is he laughing he's
snowing that's [ __ ] evil
[Music]
that was way worse so much worse i like
how he didn't ask us if we're ready he
just like he just said let's go
he's like i know you're ready
i'm ready so you're ready right that was
uh
that was something my man's [ __ ]
laughing at the storm
he's very aggressive that
i'm gonna die man i'm trying to like
form words in my brain right now but all
i can like all i'm getting is adrenaline
i'm sorry if i can't form words next
track let's go
hi
fountain
oh my god
my favorite
yes
oh no
i have no idea what to expect
now that i've experienced this is sex
even all that great i don't know anymore
well we wanted someone crazy
we were quite unprepared for how crazy
this man would be like i knew i was in
for something when i heard the laugh if
this is where we die and this is found
footage
you have my permission to clickbait the
[ __ ] out of this he was looking at it
though
oh my god
this is like an executioner showing like
the murder weapon before the excuse
i think i know why it's your favorite
yeah
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
i love you guys
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
madman he's insane imagine like being a
psychopath and getting paid for it he
was like he was laughing the whole time
every time he went over a turn you can't
even say that he's like
the worst part is right is that half the
time he wasn't looking at the road he
was looking at us he was looking
everywhere
he was like a predator just like like
by praying on his prey like he was he
was he was savouring every moment there
was like a psychopath that hijacked the
car i was saying earlier i'm never gonna
be able to get erection normally ever
again after that how can you do that
like on on roller coasters i scream but
it's more like a whoo
this is like the first
this is like the first time i've had
like a guttural oh [ __ ] i am going to
die scream like pretty sure i'm pretty
sure i will help scream like three times
my throat's [ __ ] dead so that gives
you an indication how can i go back to
my shitty little car drifted around in
my little pond
immediately well this guy is like going
down a [ __ ] mountain at
50 miles an hour stop and then
re-initiate the drift yeah yeah it was
insane like i'm actually poor i can't
believe it
i felt good about myself before lunch
now i feel like pathetic
i'm glad i didn't need much lunch
because it would definitely be up by now
oh yeah it would be on the windshield
right now all right that's all right
who's going to win the challenge though
that's still what we came here to do
we've got to go back to our challenges
so i'm going to win i'm ready
i need to i need to do one successful
drift
let's do one doughnut we got this we got
this all right let's go after having our
lives flash before our eyes multiple
times it was time to go back to
practicing our pity little donuts
but thankfully we had a new maneuver to
learn
handbrake time
and home so accelerate and clutch down
handbrake
easy yeah
this is gonna be easy are you gonna sit
this one out joe you're gonna you're
gonna join i'm gonna watch you guys oh
okay oh okay
a little baby i'm gonna i hurt my hands
so i'm gonna watch them go head over tip
as we say in australia just absolutely
hopefully not touch wood
having experienced the real thing we
were now hyped and motivated to tear it
up in our own cars well
at least most of us were yeah so uh
i decided to show this one because uh
well
hands hurting but also
[ __ ] that
mine my friend friend monkey friend hi
monkey
oh my god cool well [ __ ] me it's just me
now being the natural that i was i was
confident that i could continue my
performance with the handbrake turn
that's hard that's so hard i've got my
lucky charm with me now my elephant i
shall call you drifty you got this guard
come on you got this can't [ __ ] go if
i stole the car
he stole this car
this is the exact reason why i wanted to
sit this one out because i'd be stalling
there on the start line for like 10
minutes before i can finally do it i was
hyping myself up so much
whoa
that was hard
all right first attempt was a failure
joey might have been sitting this one
out but that was fine as i seem to have
channeled his driving skills
god [ __ ] damn it this is why i don't
drive manual
he just knocked the cones over that's so
funny
and i just stalled again
brilliant that's 100 percent
wow yeah waiting for god was he having a
chit chat what's he talking about ah so
so so uh i i reckon ganking do it god's
probably gonna nail this one just can't
do normal drift that's such a god move
he just knocked another cone over this
man can't help himself and i was just
having a great time watching the boys
murder these poor cones god's like
[ __ ] murdering these cones left and
right like every time he's just like all
right i've got to go down again fix the
cone i can't stop yielding the cone
oh you got this corner you got this i
got this come on i gotta do it
what was that
eventually though
i might have done a small oopsie that
was the scariest sound i've ever heard
what did that do to the car i don't know
but it sounded like something just
snapped
oh okay
no no good oh should i bring it up
machine change okay okay yeah sure what
happened there i think i like popped the
engine or something i gotta go and
change the engine holy [ __ ] so i [ __ ]
up i [ __ ] destroyed the engine
gotta say though it's a lot of fun while
nobody's watching i'm just gonna
secretly do it i'm just going to do it
now
connor's taking my car because
apparently he's uh destroyed his but
somehow he didn't just stop there
too early too early
what
oh i think i stopped the car has connor
broken another car surely he can't have
broken two cars
two cars in one sitting i [ __ ] two
cars i [ __ ] my own car and i [ __ ]
joey's car
no way has he broken two cars there he
got [ __ ] giggling away in his car
how does he keep destroying cars like
this
this man's the most expensive thing on
the shoe as the end of the day was
nearing we knew what time was coming it
was time to put everything we had
learned to the test connor's destroyed
not only my car but his own car so now
we have to do this time trial in god's
car yep you've destroyed this engine so
much not even the people who own this
place alike know what the [ __ ] yeah they
look really confused yeah they're like
what's happening i don't know what
happened the first one i think i i
didn't bring the clutch up and i think i
just shredded the clutch like an idiot
but the second one i don't know what
happened he they said they were pushing
and they're like it's the battery it's
the battery i'm like what here's how the
test would work it would be a time trial
around a course first we would do a
right hand drift around a cone three
times as cleanly as we could then do
three left hand turns around another
cone which we had never practiced before
except for yours truly and then after
all of that come around and finish with
a clean handbrake turn and depending on
how well we performed the maneuvers
according to our teachers we would get
time shaven off
easy right
that seems legit
easy easy so the teacher just did it in
47 seconds he went around like five
times he did it more than the intended
and because he perfectly parallel parked
that's minus five seconds so it's 42
seconds so that's the time to beat
i'm gonna floor this like my life
depends on it
i'm gonna die i'm just gonna not be able
to do this do we have a punishment that
we can do lose a place for dinner
tonight that's how we'll do it all right
i can't wait to have my succulent meal
provided for free
by joey
watch me eat my own words like i [ __ ]
always do what could possibly go wrong
joey would you like to go first your car
possibly go right come on jerry you sure
about this yeah yeah why not
i mean you're going to be here for a
while yeah it's fine that's fine it's 40
seconds right yeah
we'll get there i'll be back in 30.
with my sustained injuries and my
complete lack of manual driving
experience i was the first one on the
chopping block all i needed to do was to
not stall at the very start of the race
i actually think he's going to do better
than me because he's he's been able to
drift it i haven't been able to do a
single thing is there if you stall you
lose like five
you just
he's just stopped
yes we start the timer now right we're
starting the timer now no no
unfortunately
all
right he's doing one more he's doing one
more
it's a wide
i've ever seen one
he's [ __ ] doing it well let's see his
handbrake turn let's see this
[Music]
happens it well done joey my hand is
hurting so much right now i can't
believe i [ __ ] survived that [ __ ]
god's going next fantastic can't wait
seeing joey doing a relatively clean run
the pressure is on me to not make a
complete fool of myself alright here we
go if he stalls i'm gonna laugh my ass
off
[Music]
oh [ __ ] she went over
here again
just making sure i think
me
oh nice
oh
i don't know how i did that i forgot to
speak this entire time i forgot to even
do an intro
i was just running on pure adrenaline
finally it was my turn i've seen the
other boys do their trial i was pretty
sure i could destroy them all i needed
to do was not [ __ ] this up and keep
doing what i was doing in practice and i
would easily win this connor is either
going to absolutely destroy us in time
or destroy the car
oh no
no
no
he's still
i [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up
i [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up that went
well that went so well
[ __ ] thank you thank you
oh i stalled
corner once again acing acing the
training arc and then when the time
really comes
when it comes down to it
acing the acing the fake protagonist
litmus test with flying colors right now
as the one with food poisoning i'm glad
i'm not the one that [ __ ] myself today
[ __ ] plot armor again
i've got the antagonist [ __ ] that
makes me lose what it matters most i
hate being an antagonist
you always lose you never win
it's because i didn't have my monkey
where the [ __ ] is my monkey if i had my
monkey wouldn't have lost that would not
have lost that just saying hey buddy
how you doing buddy
big sad i can't believe i [ __ ] it all
i stalled as well the moment i stalled i
was like right i've got to think about
excuses right yeah
not used to the car the clutch was weird
yeah it was my car which i didn't break
uh i'd have won that easy love the fact
that you started off bad and i was like
he's going to recover yeah yeah yeah
proceed to [ __ ] hit the cone and just
drag it 10 miles with you
you took out you took out a cone and a
gopro like like we were like circling
the cone where we were supposed to and
you're in [ __ ] narnia
i wanted i wanted my drifts to be the
sickest and that made me lose all right
chris tell us the results go second and
wait my second note always put me out of
my misery chris okay in [ __ ] place
is connor
is that like one hour 24 minutes
it felt like that long hours 24 minutes
and collateral damage along the way one
minute 24 minutes 25 minutes i was going
to say chris come on man don't embarrass
me more than i already have
24 seconds 25 milliseconds in second
place
is joey
one minute seven seconds in first place
is gone one minute one second he's
running around the protagonist
protagonist this is [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] i always lose in the
right time
i was the best the whole time so i'm
thinking family mart for dinner uh
nothing special i don't want to go a5
wagyu
i'm down for that
well domino's maybe at most like i don't
really want to break the bank we'll get
the expense of dominance
if each of you could summarize the
experience in one word what would that
word be
uh
sexy
i was gonna sexy i was gonna say
erection orgasmic yeah but uh big big
big thank you to uh absolute drifting
yeah for letting us film and uh letting
us do all sorts of wacky shenanigans
like this and also thank you to the
patrons yeah because it wasn't for you
guys we wouldn't be here we won't be
doing this video very expensive video it
was a very expensive this was a very
expensive video and if you're wondering
where the budget for patreon goes
this
this is just the beginning we want to do
all sorts of crazy projects this is just
a taster and if you liked what you saw
then consider supporting us on patreon
yeah patreon.com trash taste links in
the description i'm going to avenge
myself for the next special your special
next special i'm gonna [ __ ] do why do
i feel like the cartoon [ __ ] villain
that never wins dude
the whole race the whole race he's in
first
all right how much is it [ __ ]
that's
not that's 130 dollars
for the four of us though
it's pretty good yeah it's good value
for money
yeah goodbye for money guys great value
for you
[Music]
how was that guys how was that hilarious
and cool because i didn't lose
you know i i will say that i actually
think you deserve to win there i think
your
performance to win i deserve to win what
do you mean
i'm sorry both of you were like [ __ ]
sunday drivers going around those
i will say on a technical level i think
joey that second cone you [ __ ] did a
clean drift cleaner than either of us
that's a lie what can i say i watched
all the initial d before you win all
right like i got in the zone
i feel like slander and i won't i feel
like i got a technical i i could feel
like a technical knockout with my win
yeah but like i'm gonna get i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it to joey i feel like
joey's performance on the day one was
the best connor you were just doing your
own thing you know you were just having
a mosey around on a sunday morning just
like it don't matter how good you
perform before the time that matters
it's how you perform on the day exactly
it doesn't matter how hard you study in
class if you [ __ ] up in the test you're
[ __ ] up in the test all right it's
it's called the drifter kangaroo not the
practice trip to king you know
i'm gonna win next time
anyway we hope you enjoyed that special
uh the reason we wanted to do this is we
enjoyed the acaba video so much that we
just kind of wanted to see what it would
be like if we were doing different
things outside you know outside of the
studio and going above and beyond our
comfort zone yeah exactly this is
something that we had never challenged
ourselves to at all and honestly is
probably a type of content that you
probably would have never seen on any of
our individual channels right and you
know because all of you guys support us
on patreon so freaking much like way
more than what we were expecting we
wanted to give back to you guys right
yeah we we we wanted to show you what we
could achieve with all the
generosity that you've given because we
did not expect trash tapes to be there i
don't know if we mentioned this but this
entire episode was funded by you guys on
patreon like a lot of you guys are like
where is this patreon money going it's
going into stuff like this yeah and this
is just the first of many this is this
isn't going to interrupt your regular
broadcast we just wanted to show you a
taste of what's to come a trash taste of
what's become
we have so many plans for you guys and
and we know that this can be so much
bigger than it is and if you want to
help support that and support our
craziness and all the dumb hijinks that
we're gonna get up to go ahead to the
trash taste patreon and uh support us
there please please support the patreon
if you enjoyed what you saw this was a
very expensive day not just not just for
like the cars and everything that we
[ __ ] broke on the day yeah but for
all the equipment and the [ __ ] crew
that we needed shout out to chris abroad
in japan by the way yeah yeah shout out
to chris because like i don't know if we
ever like mentioned
there was never a point in the video
where it was like he was organically
introduced he was just he was kind of
just there
it's just like yeah chris is abroad in
japan and just there that whole shoot
would have fallen apart if chris wasn't
there to drive us yeah because we none
of us had a license at the time the
driver car so we actually needed chris
otherwise we've been [ __ ] so yeah
please go over to the patreon and also
go subscribe to abroad in japan without
him this video wouldn't have been half
as good thank you but uh yeah again like
if you know the bigger the patreon gets
the more ambitious we can be with the
more crazy ideas we can do we have some
crazy ideas that we think we can pull
off yeah but we have some can be
expensive crazy ideas that haven't been
done on youtube yeah
but you know whether we get to fund it
or not is remains to be seen but in the
meantime hope you enjoyed that and hope
you enjoy what we are able to make next
yep hopefully it'll be bigger and better
than this yes thank you so much for
watching and supporting us have a good
day i'll see you in the next episode bye
[Music]
you